in the future the bed I always hope will
be a democratic elected leadership power
of people people spell it is Raymond oh
and you applying the longer the great
patient war yes thank you okay the Dalai
Lama wants to make sure I speak with the
current city on their term for a prime
minister please sit down is Tibet ever
coming back
absolutely yeah you believe that
absolutely but everything suggests
otherwise
no because you asked me this question
here in Bodhgaya where Buddha did
something impossible attained
enlightenment and Buddhism is 2500 plus
years old
communism is just what hundreds of years
old one part is old is less than hundred
years old there is no competition
between the two we must have dialogue
between the N voice of the dial AMA and
Chinese representatives and Tibetans
should be granted genuine autonomy as
per Chinese laws within China but you
are no I exist in a political world and
I play hardball
Tibetans we see China in a different way
our perspectives read different we have
live side by side for thousands of years
so we kind of know them better than
anyone in the world so hence we don't
fear China we are not amazed by China
we're not exactly what they're doing our
time will come our opportunity to come
the Prime Minister's optimism comes from
outside the political sphere he sees
this it seems as a war of ideas and
takes comfort from the longevity of the
Buddhist culture in a time when the
world seems to be in turmoil a turmoil
I've seen firsthand as a journalist in
Afghanistan and Iraq and beyond I have
to wonder
Kettner Dalai Lama's message of hope
prevail
[Music]
[Music]